I'm proud to present coming straight to
you from a beautiful villa in Rome Italy
the world's very first noodle chair a
portion of this video was sponsored by
LastPass now let's go
Vsauce Kevin here with a very simple
engineering project all you need is a
phone disk some spaghetti and suddenly
you're demonstrating the compressive
strength that allows tiny rods of pasta
to hold up the weight of a hardcover
book when I saw this I thought to myself
what if I'm the book can pasta hold me
and then LastPass came along and they
said Kevin we'd like to work with you on
creating your dream video and I said my
dream is to build a noodle chair in
Italy and they said hahaha no but really
and I said hahaha yes but really so I'm
gonna do it I am literally going to fly
to Italy and build a chair out of
noodles while I travel over 4,000 miles
to Rome let me thank LastPass for
sponsoring this video if you don't know
about LastPass I use it for all my
logins I was tired of forgetting
passwords getting locked out of accounts
or dealing with websites that have
different rules about what a password
could even be so I got LastPass and it
automatically fills my usernames and
passwords everywhere safely and securely
with unlimited password storage and
cross-device
sync thanks again to LastPass for
sponsoring this portion of the video so
if you want to eliminate your password
frustrations forever
click the link down in the description
below I am in Rome
and if you're gonna build a chair out of
noodles you need to hire the big guns
so I've flown in two competitors from
the world spaghetti bridge building
championship in Budapest Hungary
introducing Norbert
they're here from Alberta University to
represent wretch the annual world
championships and spaghetti bridge
building we're using just spaghetti and
epoxy competitors build bridges that
support hundreds of times their own
weight
these goliaths of gluten truly are pasta
engineers and it's time to procure the
noodles that we need to hold my heinie
we all jumped in a taxi from the villa
to the supermarket to get our pasta I
mean we're in Italy there's no reason to
bring your own noodles from home right
wrong that was a mistake in the World
Championships Johnny and Norby used pure
durum wheat pasta for its amazing
strength they panicked when all they
could find at the market was cannelloni
with egg added to it it honestly never
occurred to me that an entire aisle
filled with pasta wouldn't have what the
guys were looking for but it didn't
without action what's plan B we kindly
asked an employee to help us find
eggless noodles but even with the
language barrier it was pretty clear we
weren't going to find the catalonia we
needed here's why it's a problem egg is
added to pasta to help give it a yellow
color to add some additional nutritional
value and to influence water absorption
but it also changes the pasta structure
egg noodles are more brittle than what
norbi and Johnny usually use in material
science brittleness matters it's the
measure of how much stress a material
can absorb before breaking durum wheat
strong egg but we didn't have any other
choice it was egg or nothing our only
course of action was to grab life by the
yolks and call upon Ceres the roman
goddess of agriculture and wheat to
bless our egg fortified noodles if our
pleas go unanswered what's the worst
that can happen I fall through the chair
and break my tailbone okay and that
would be bad please hold
egg cannelloni please all right so we're
back from the store on our epic pasta
run and here's what we've got we've got
five boxes of bucatini sixteen boxes of
cannelloni one box of lasagne one bag of
extra long spaghetti five boxes of epoxy
one tube of silicone five boxes of
superfast epoxy a bag of silicon discs a
pile of wooden support blocks a digital
caliper various tools and six metal
dowels that were supposed to be wooden
dowels but uh well here's a little
reenactment of what happened when we
found out no one brought wooden dowels
Nobby hand me a towel I didn't leave it
ours did you bring the tower's I thought
you brought ours
why do you guys need dowels to make
straight cubes like this you can break
my light stand apart if you like anyway
now that we have everything that we need
to create our magnificent noodle chair
that means it's time for one thing and
one thing only and that is to whip out
our noodles we've absorbed egg adversity
we've dealt with a dowel disaster
against all odds was finally time to
start building our noodle chair first
let's talk about the sticky stuff we're
using epoxy because it's not a
water-based adhesive that way it won't
soak into the noodles and compromise
their integrity it also creates rigid
joints that transfer force to the
noodles because we want the noodles
themselves to bear all the weight a
chair made entirely out of epoxy resin
would support thousands of pounds but
that kind of defeats the purpose of what
we're doing here we want to push the
limits of pasta and we don't have a lot
of time because epoxy takes a full 24
hours to cure Norby and Johnny needed to
build fast so Norby and Johnny started
by building the chair seat out of
meticulously selected pieces of
cannelloni a cylindrical noodle that's
often filled with ricotta cheese
we're not however gonna fill our chair
with cheese we're not gonna fill our
chair with cheese they've gone through
box after box to find the best shaped
cannelloni so they're grind of the most
consistent noodles will have the highest
structural integrity you know what they
say one wonky noodle and we've got a
serious weak point nobody says that
and that's when a quality-control
calamity struck it turned out one brand
of the cannelloni that we bought was
almost completely worthless because
nearly all of the noodles were miss
shapen and most of the nicely shaped
ones had
we needed perfect cylinders so in an
instant our supply of materials was cut
in half at this point we officially had
no room for error
the top and bottom layers are composed
of fourteen three noodle rows and the
top layer is rotated 90 degrees to cross
the grain like a plywood composite this
increases the stiffness of the material
which is a measure of its ability to
resist deformation from an applied force
in this case my butt the seat will
transfer the force to three legs each of
which are comprised of three pipes of
cannelloni every piece is sanded
carefully so the joined surfaces are as
close to perfect as possible and then
they're constructed into a tube using
our tripod dowels as a mold and jig the
three tubes are then attached to make a
chair leg that distributes force through
one of the strongest shapes in
engineering an equilateral triangle
Norby and Gianni worked straight through
until 5 a.m.
planning measuring grinding and gluing
until they finished what they needed to
and as the Sun rose over roma the
hard-working hungarians collapsed
[Music]
Bongiorno
it is now day two noodle construction
went on until 5:00 a.m. this morning and
the lingering question I have in my mind
is this why does boiling pasta turn a
hard thing soft but boiling an egg turns
a soft thing hard
[Music]
and weirdly enough both processes are
the result of the same thing water
retention let's start with the egg the
proteins and eggs mostly albumin are
compacted with weak bonds think of them
like clumps of cord that don't really
interact with each other when heated the
collision with excited water molecules
makes them all smash together and those
bonds break causing the proteins to
unfold then the unfolded proteins tangle
all together creating new bonds there's
still a lot more water present than
protein but the water is now divided up
among countless little pockets in the
continuous protein network so it can't
flow together anymore and thus a liquid
egg has become a moist solid moist solid
sounds gross okay but why does boiling
spaghetti make it soft because it
rehydrates the pasta okay cool wait what
does that mean well uncooked pasta is
basically a zillion raw starch granules
embedded in a matrix of gluten protein
when cooked in water starch granules at
and near the noodles surface absorb
water
swell soften and release some dissolved
starch into the cooking water this
process is called gelatinize ation and
we can visualize this using super
absorbent polymer spheres just imagine
these spheres are these starch granules
inside the spaghetti rehydrating it into
these soft delicious noodles ready for
saucing
let's get back to our chair and day 2 is
when Johnny and Norby decided to
radically change the chairs design their
original plan was to build a chair with
three legs crossed in mutual support
early on the second day they decided to
add a fourth leg for a more traditional
chair that meant building another leg
that we hoped would dry and cure in time
to be tested because with so many
problems and Gamble's already why not
push our luck
then it was Brooker teeny time bucatini
is like a thick spaghetti with a hole in
the middle so it was the perfect choice
for a top layer for the seat that could
evenly distribute downward force to the
cannelloni layer johnny nor be braced
the bucatini with strips of lasagna for
even more strength oh and a chair needs
a back doesn't it it does they put
together a simple open back with rows of
noodles similar to the seat the joint
between the back and the seat just isn't
going to be very strong without many
layers of lasagna so this one's gonna be
delicate but just as you'd expect the
legs are pretty much everything when it
comes to holding my weight if the legs
don't work the chair don't work so they
attach the legs to the seat using
silicone pads to give a bit more surface
area to make up for the gaps between the
cannelloni then it was about leg to
floor contact they precision sanded the
feet to just the right angle so that all
four would rest evenly on the floor if
just one leg is too far off the downward
force from my body will be distributed
unevenly which means the other legs will
have to absorb additional stress and
that's bad with the egg noodle
uncertainty a dwindling supply of
acceptable cannelloni and the clock
ticking on epoxy curing time they used
extra long spaghetti to attach flat
support beams between the four
cannelloni legs look when you're quickly
building a noodle chair every little bit
helps
here's a question why are we using
cannelloni
we chose cannelloni because they're a
lot like these ionic columns from Greek
and Roman architecture
now when building noodle furniture some
of the things to consider are the
noodles tensile strength which is its
ability to resist tension that will
elongate and break it then compressive
strength which is withstanding force
that compresses the noodle and then it's
shear strength which is its ability to
handle parallel forces acting upon it
it's crunch time it's the eleventh hour
the Sun is going down soon and we need
to test this chair we all have flights
to catch with the back assembled to the
seat and the legs as sturdy and precise
as they can get from our incorrect
noodles we're finally ready to Oh God
the back broke yeah so the back is just
broken off our noodle chair we didn't
even see what happened one minute it was
great the other minute it was not we
didn't even get it on video because
there was nothing to film we weren't
gonna record hours of glue drying but
despite the back tragedy norbi and
Johnny's scrambled to reattach and
reinforce the back so we'd be ready for
testing and finally to finish things off
we added a little spaghetti Flair hey
we're in Italy
design matters the Flavian dynasty built
Rome's Colosseum Michelangelo painted
the ceiling of the Sistine Chapel in
Vatican City and here in a cozy Roman
villa
norbi and Johnny present to me their
noodle chair well there are days we're
done what do you think I hope it's a
person I think it's right
I'm proud to present coming straight to
you from a beautiful villa in Rome Italy
the world's very first noodle chair
[Music]
to make this video I assembled a team
from Budapest Hungary Bristol England
Cooperstown New York and Las Vegas
Nevada collectively we traveled 47
thousand seven hundred and seventy-six
kilometers that 7701 kilometers more
than the circumference of Earth to a
three acre villa in the heart of Rome
Italy and we spent day and night
building a chair out of noodles and now
for the very first time none of us have
tested this yet I'm gonna sit on it and
if it works it works and if it doesn't
work
[Music]
here we go
it works it totally worked
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Hungarian engineering at its finest I
gotta brace myself it's going down well
it turns out if you dumb canoodle chair
in a pool and then sit on it it will
break the ends
[Music]
the ricotta removed
Masuda this thanks to norbi and johnny
and the rich world spaghetti building
championship and huge thanks to dom
burgess for shooting this whole thing he
has a science youtube channel called
every think i'll put a link down in the
description below he's got a video on
how to build a time machine how when we
find aliens they'll be robots you want
to go subscribe to every thing if you
liked this video i mean i thought it was
a lot of fun to make let me know if
you'd like to see more stuff like this
and as always grazie for watching
[Music]
[Applause]